it's time for my favorite story segue
hey this is kind of a weird thing Donald
and Melania Trump in the spirit of
Christmas Spoke the kids on the phone
about where Santa is on his gift
delivery trip okay fine whatever it's a
Christmas tradition of some kind for the
president I guess
so clearly the kids that they're
speaking to I guess believe in Santa
so Trump gets on the phone with a
seven-year-old kid named Coleman and
says to the kid that belief in Santa at
age seven is marginal now if the kid
believes in Santa this isn't really a
conversation to have with the kid right
take a listen to this video we just
spoke on the bonus show last week about
belief in Santa and I explained I never
believed in Santa being Jewish when I
was growing up there was never a
situation where I thought Santa was real
and I don't really have a recollection
about when my classmates realized that
Santa wasn't real I know that my sister
who's half Jewish stopped believing in
Santa on her own around seven or eight
but it doesn't seem like it's the
president who should be telling kids
that there's no Santa on calls arranged
to tell kids where Santa is like doesn't
something about this seem weirdly grinch
like yeah I found out that Santa wasn't
real pretty early on like I was 6 or 7
years old and I immediately told all my
friends because I just could not contain
myself you know that's something that's
acceptable if you're only 6 or 7 years
old and you can't really weigh the
consequences of your actions but if
you're like 72 I think you should know
better if I found out that my kid at
school was going around telling other
kids that there was no Santa I'd
probably tell the teacher you know I
don't I don't really see a problem I'm
not gonna tell my kids to lie but if
you're president and you're talking to
kids about Santa
doesn't seem like what you should be
doing and I mentioned this to you number
one because it's been Christmas and
we're doing something a little more
lighthearted even though it again shows
that Trump is capable of screwing up
even the smallest things I was thinking
of the Santa thing sort of like swearing
like I don't swear much but I don't
think swearing's a big deal and in
Argentina where I was born swearing on
TV is just really not a huge deal
swearing at school or at home you don't
do it excessively but it's it's just not
a big deal if my kids teacher called and
said your son or daughter is swearing in
school I would say I really don't see
that as a problem but I would explain it
can be disruptive you should pare down
the swearing but in and of itself I
don't see swearing as a big deal but it
would be really weird if the president
called my seven-year-old kid and was
swearing up a storm on the phone that I
would find to be just a little bit
strange in the same manner it's strange
for Trump to have scheduled calls with
kids to talk about Santa and talk about
belief in Santa being marginal with a
seven-year-old and for anyone who is
comfortable with Trump winging it in
meetings with foreign leaders this is
what happens when Trump wings it okay
he's told he's gonna make calls to kids
about Santa and nobody says by the way
these kids think Santa is real maybe is
the president you shouldn't lose to
Santa nah being real Trump decided to
wing it and this is what happens
just imagine what is happening in
Singapore when Trump wings it with Kim
jong-un or at the g20 or at the UN when
the entire crowd starts laughing at
Trump because he says such silly things
we don't want Trump winging things
because he's able to screw up even the
most minor presidential appearances